gut versteckte stollen und tunnel gebaut
von einem verbrecherischen regime
egal wie gesund du warst als du rein
gegangen bist schon nach ein paar wochen
fing dein körper an praktisch
auseinander zu fallen
eine geisterstadt mit einem verborgenen
schatz
den man braucht schon einen guten grund
um hierher zu kommen um all die
anstrengungen und gefahren auf sich zu
nehmen
ein ehemals friedliches dorf zerstört
vom krieg der level and destruction hier
muss etwas wirklich einschneidende es
passiert sein
und geheimnisvolle ruinen mit giftiger
vergangenheit
auf das gelände ist eingezäunt damit
niemand darum läuft und sich vergiftet
aber man sieht das labyrinth das
angelegt wurde
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht
doch wer waren ihre erbauer wie wurden
sie errichtet und warum wurden sie
verlassen
[Musik]
in der abgeschiedenen wildnis im süden
des us bundesstaates montana legt ein
verlassenes tal mit einer dunklen
vergangenheit
es ist schwer in dieser gegend zu leben
es gibt kaum wasser im winter wird es
extrem kalt es ist eins der am dünnsten
besiedelten gebiete im ganzen land
auf den ersten blick wirkt die gegend
menschenleer aber das war einmal ganz
anders eine geheimnisvolle geisterstadt
beweist es
wenn man in die stadt hinein kommt
könnte man meinen dass dort noch
menschen wohnen die gebäude wirken als
sei die zeit eingefroren nur die
bewohner sind irgendwie verschwunden
das war eine komplette kleinstadt mit
der nötigen infrastruktur für eine
größere zahl einwohner die aus einem
bestimmten grund hier war
aber was die leute hier wollten darauf
lässt die geisterstadt keine schlüsse zu
den ersten hinweis auf die geschichte
dieser siedlung liefert ihre besondere
lage
alle gebäude sind mehr oder weniger
direkt am flussufer gebaut man fragt
sich ob es dabei wirklich nur um die
wasserversorgung ging
was hat die menschen hierher gelockt
über jahrhunderte etwas wertvolles in
der erde und in den flüssen etwas für
das es sich zu töten lohnt
jetzt deutet nichts mehr darauf hin aber
das war früher eine der gefährlichsten
städte in ganz amerika morde
raubüberfälle schießereien lynchjustiz
was war der grund für diese ganze gewalt
um das tal ranken sich gerüchte die
einfach nicht verstummen wollen
irgendwo hier in der gegend ganz in der
nähe ist ein großer schatz vergraben
die legende über die verborgenen
reichtümer ist nur eine der mythen
dieser stadt
die grausamen geschichten über raubmord
und verrat die über diese stadt
kursieren stammen aus der zeit des
wilden westens
alles begann in den 1800 60er jahren wie
parkranger john phillips zu erzählen
weiß
[Musik]
im juli 1862 waren john white und seine
männer auf dem weg zum salmon river zur
stadt florence und stießen unterwegs auf
diesen fluss
wie tausende andere in der mitte des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts reisen die
pioniere durch die usa auf der suche
nach einem besseren leben und in der
hoffnung erreicht zu werden
sie tauchten ihre pfannen in den fluss
fühlten sich durch den kies und suchten
nach schwarzem sand und tatsächlich nach
einem schnellen test wussten sie dass
sie gefunden hatten was sie suchten
gold
von wald und seine männer haben den
jackpot geknackt denn das ist nicht
einfach nur gold es ist 99 prozent 3
dieser fund war der anfang des
goldrauschs im heutigen montaner
innerhalb von wochen waren es hunderte
innerhalb von monaten waren es tausende
menschen die hier reich werden wollten
indem sie in diesem kleinen fluss nach
gold suchten
das ist der anfang der goldgräberstadt
banic die schnell einen gewaltigen boom
erlebt
hier standen häuser und zelte und wagen
so weit man gucken konnte
überall waren leute es gab so lins
bordelle geschäfte alles mögliche hier
war jede menge los
aber der plötzliche reichtum zieht auch
kriminelle an
sobald den leuten klar wurde dass es in
diesem fluss gold gab war die gier
stärker als alles andere recht und
gesetz das waren höchstens zweitrangige
kategorien
gesetze hatten praktisch keine bedeutung
mehr
gangster wurden angezogen wie motten vom
licht
in den hügeln rund um die stadt wimmelte
es von banditen
es gab mord und totschlag
auch in einer wild west statt wie berg
muss die kriminalität irgendwann unter
kontrolle gebracht werden die
gesetzlosigkeit kann nicht ewig
weitergehen
[Musik]
schließlich kommt ein sheriff in die
stadt mit ein paar hilfssheriffs er will
endlich für recht und ordnung sorgen
tatsächlich
der neue sheriff heißt henry plan er hat
eine bewegte und etwas undurchsichtige
vergangenheit
er war selbst ein erfolgreicher
goldgräber gewesen und schon in jungen
jahren reich geworden
es heißt dass er mehrere menschen
getötet habe aber nie im gefängnis war
1863 wird er dann zum scherrer von berg
gewählt er hatte versprochen recht und
ordnung wiederherzustellen
zuerst sieht es so aus als wolle er sich
an seinen versprechen halten wer ärger
macht wird ins neu gebaute gefängnis
gesperrt
[Musik]
das ist das erste gefängnis in montana
man kann sich vorstellen wie es hier im
winter war
henry planer hatte viele facetten nach
außen gab er den ehrlichen fleißigen
gesetzeshüter der das gefängnis gebaut
hat
aber in wirklichkeit ist ja nicht ganz
so lupenrein wie wir gerne glauben
wollen
[Musik]
klammer ist mehr als er zu sein vorgibt
trotz der vergeblichen bemühungen des
neuen sheriffs wird die gewalt in belek
nicht weniger es wird noch schlimmer
was also ist mit henry planer passiert
und was hat er mit der alten legende
über einen vergrabenen schatz zu tun
das verbrechen greift immer weiter um
sich irgendwann beschließen ein paar
männer aus der stadt die sache selbst in
die hand zu nehmen
der sheriff und seine leute schafften es
nicht für ruhe und ordnung in der stadt
zu sorgen
daraufhin schlossen sich einige männer
zu einer bürgerwehr zusammen um etwas
gegen die kriminalität zu tun
die maskierten männer der bürgerwehr
gehen auf die jagd nach vermeintlichen
verbrechern wenn sie einen schnappen
machen sie kurzen prozess
will die ganze stadt war durchsetzt von
korruption und was wirklich spannend ist
der pate dieser ganzen mafia war
offenbar der chef selbst
ein gerücht macht die runde planer sei
in wirklichkeit der kopf einer
berüchtigten banditen bande bekannt als
wie innozenz die unschuldigen im januar
1864 schlägt die bürgerwehr schließlich
zu
in einer eiskalten nacht nahm die
bürgerwehr prammer und seine
hilfssheriffs in ihren häusern und im
saloon fest sie brachten sie hierher auf
dieses gelände da drüben und knüpften
alle drei männer am galgen auf
aber stimmt das gerücht über henry
planer wirklich eine geschichte über die
letzten minuten seines lebens könnte es
bestätigen
der legende zufolge soll klammer auf dem
weg zum galgen um sein leben gebettelt
haben als gegenleistung soll er
versprochen haben zu verraten wo er
seinen goldschatz vergraben hatte im
damaligen wert von 100.000 dollar
aber auch nach dem tod des sheriffs hört
die gewalt nicht auf manche glauben die
bürger wer selbst hätte von anfang an
hinter den verbrechen gesteckt
was auch immer die wahrheit ist berg
bleibt ein ort der gesetzlosen bis ab
1870 langsam das gold versiegt mit tanz
wenn in so einem ort der einzige grund
für die leute dort zu sein wegfällt dann
gehen sie die nur ganz wenige blieben
aber was ist mit dem vergrabenen schatz
des sheriffs
was ist mit dem gold mit dem planer sein
leben retten wollte
gab es das wirklich es wurde nie
gefunden
[Musik]
nur eine kleine gruppe hart gesottener
bleibt in belek aber bis in die 1950 er
sind alle weg und aus der berüchtigten
goldgräberstadt wird ein
naturschutzgebiet aber die legenden gibt
es bis heute
bei sheriff planer wirklich der führende
kopf der organisierten kriminalität in
berneck
wird sein schatz je gefunden werden
wir wollten sie ihn loswerden weil er
böse war oder weil er gut war
niemand weiß das ganz sicher
[Musik]
tief in den wäldern des eulen gebirges
im südwesten polens liegt der geheime
eingang zu einer düsteren unterwelt
von außen sieht es nicht nach viel aus
aber wenn du nach unten gehst ist es
riesig und es ist alles massiver fels
dunkle tunnel führen in unheimliche
seele und zu gefluteten höhlen sind sie
auf natürlichem wege entstanden oder
deuten sie auf eine dunkle vergangenheit
in dieser sorte fans würden sich
normalerweise nicht solche höhen
ausbilden
das hat menschen gebaut
jemand hat großen aufwand betrieben um
diese unterirdische anlage in den fels
zu schlagen
etwas wertvolles dort abbauen oder etwas
wertvolles dort versteckt
draußen im wald setzt sich das rätsel
fort was sind das für betonklötze
und wer hat diese ausgedehnte anlage
gebaut
wer auch immer das gebaut hat die
arbeitsbedingungen müssen schlimm
gewesen sein
dieses bauwerk entstand unter
entsetzlichen leiden im auftrag eines
menschenverachtenden regimes
dieser ort zeigt dass menschen zu allem
bereit sind
sogar höhe in einen berg zu schlagen und
die todesmaschine am laufen zu halten
der polnische schriftsteller ego
wittkowski kennt die anlage und ihre
geheimnisse besser als irgendjemand
sonst
die größten höhlen sind rund 100 meter
lang zwölf meter hoch und zehn meter
breit um an einen eindruck von den
dimensionen zu vermitteln
die höhlen sind so lang wie ein
fußballfeld
aber was war ihr zweck
wie wurde die anlage gebaut
und warum hier in dieser abgelegenen
gegend
dieser ort liegt weit entfernt von
besiedelten gebieten
verborgen im wald ist der komplex aus
der luft kaum zu sehen
sein bau beginnt mitten im zweiten
weltkrieg und seine fertigstellung hat
höchste priorität
1943 haben die nazis noch große teile
europas besetzt
aber langsam beginnt der anfang vom ende
des hitler regimes
in nordafrika werden die achsenmächte
endgültig besiegt die alliierten landen
erst auf sizilien und schließlich auf
dem italienischen festland
mussolini ein enger verbündeter hitlers
wird abgesetzt und schon im januar muss
die wehrmacht in stalingrad kapitulieren
nach einer der brutalsten schlachten des
ganzen krieges
auch zu see und in der luft wendet sich
das blatt die angriffe der alliierten
werden immer heftiger sie lassen bomben
auf deutsche städte regnen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er zerschlug für die deutschen ist dass
zuerst ein schock durch die
bombenangriffe der alliierten wird der
krieg sehen sehr real
als die nazis die luftüberlegenheit über
deutschland verloren mussten sie ihre
industrieanlagen irgendwie schützen
sie verlegten so viele fabriken wie
möglich tief unter die erde
aus angst vor alliierten bombern
in einem verzweifelten versuch die
drohende niederlage aufzuhalten starten
die nazis ein gigantisches bauvorhaben
es gehört zu einem streng geheimen
projekt mit dem code-namen riese
wenn man in friedenszeiten einen tunnel
komplex baut macht man das mit maschinen
die natürlich treibstoff brauchen aber
die nazis waren mitten im zweiten
weltkrieg
sie hatten keine entsprechenden
ressourcen dafür übrig
die fehlenden maschinen mögen mit dafür
verantwortlich sein dass die anlage nie
fertiggestellt wird die nazis wählen
eine andere methode
das ist eine anlage die von tausenden
zwangsarbeitern gebaut wurde
1943 44 lief praktisch die gesamte
deutsche kriegswirtschaft auch der
grundlage von zwangsarbeit
der komplex riese liegt in der nähe des
konzentrationslagers groß rosen rund
20.000 zwangsarbeiter wurden beim bau
eingesetzt
es ist wie ein kz das in einen berg
verlegt wurde
die menschen hier wurden zu tode
geschunden
es gab einen schier unerschöpflichen
nachschub an zwangsarbeitern das macht
die ganzen stollen noch unheimlicher und
dass sie alle mit dem blut den schweiß
und den tränen von zwangsarbeitern
gebaut wurden
es war eine furchtbare arbeit es muss
wie dante's inferno auf erden gewesen
sein bis zu 5000 menschen wurden beim
bau der anlage ermordet
die nazis wollen das geheime projekt um
jeden preis fertigstellen aber warum
bis heute ist nicht völlig geklärt wo zu
komplex riese dienen sollte
vermutlich sollte hier ein neues
führerhauptquartier entstehen außerdem
bunker für die oberkommandos von heer
und luftwaffe
zusätzlich industrieanlagen es gibt
viele theorien
igor wittkowski hat seine eigene
krise war teil eines größeren plans mit
dem ziel massenvernichtungswaffen zu
entwickeln und zu produzieren
große hallen wie diese hier wurden
meistens dafür genutzt um große waffen
herzustellen
flugzeuge marschflugkörper und so weiter
während die alliierten immer weiter
vorrücken suchen die deutschen
verzweifelt nach einer wunderwaffe um
sie zurück drängen zu können
wollen sie diese waffe hier produzieren
wir wollten die deutschen mit all ihrem
technischen know how und ihrer
angeblichen russischen überlegenheit die
wunderwaffen entwickeln mit denen sie
doch noch den krieg gewinnen würden
kann es sein dass hier experimentelle
waffen entwickelt werden sollten je
näher man komplex riese betrachtet desto
mysteriöser wird alles
der komplex für sich ist schon
gigantisch und in diesem gebirgszug gibt
es noch einmal fünf solcher anlagen
tatsächlich gibt es in der ganzen region
noch viel mehr solcher anlagen alle
waren gut geschützt und versteckt
und alle wurden in verschiedenen stadien
der fertigstellung aufgegeben
vermutlich sollten sie ursprünglich
einmal miteinander verbunden werden und
so eine gigantische unterirdische stadt
bilden
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich wollten die deutschen
hier den größten unterirdischen komplex
des ganzen reiches bauen aber riese
wurde nie fertig gestellt
[Musik]
die rote armee marschierte mit großen
schritten nach westen und eroberte immer
mehr gebiete von den nazis als
ich die rote armee näherte wurden die
zwangsarbeiter genau wie die anderen kz
insassen auf todesmärsche geschickt
die nazis wollten die spuren ihrer
kriegsverbrechen gründlich verwischen
ende 1944 erreichen die sowjets die
polnische hauptstadt warschau
kurz darauf geben die nazis komplex
reese auf und fliehen
bis heute gibt es viele offene fragen
über die anlage und welchem zweck sie
wirklich dienen sollte klar ist dass die
menschen die sie bauen mussten einen
schrecklichen preis zahlen
bis das ist wie ein unterirdisches
konzentrationslager
tausende menschen wurden getötet von
einem verbrecherischen regime
es ist ein moment des todes von
millionen
an der südwestlichsten spitze englands
im beschaulichen cornwall liegt ein tal
voller überwucherten ruinen
suzuki wir sind alle möglichen seltsamen
dinge zu sehen ein schornstein und
fundamente verschiedener gebäude
es ist ein ziemliches durcheinander
alle möglichen verlassenen gebäude
manche sind verschüttet manche
eingestürzt
neben den ruinen sind seltsame runde
gebilde zu sehen
lookeen bei näherer betrachtung muss
hier einiges los gewesen sein über
längere zeit
einige der gebäude sind ziemlich groß
und zum teil sehen sie aus als seien sie
eingestürzt oder abgerissen worden oder
sonst irgendwie zerstört
von den zahlreichen gebäuden die hier
einmal standen ist nicht mehr viel übrig
billy may die natur hat sich einen teil
der landschaft zurück erobert das ist
klar aber vielleicht gab es ja auch eine
explosion was hat diese zerstörung
angerichtet
wenn man genau hinsieht kann man
entschlüsseln was hier passiert ist
es politik in diesem teil cornwalls
finden sich die hinweise nicht an der
oberfläche sondern darunter
unter dem grünen gras liegt eine giftige
vergangenheit begraben
aber wie wurde dieses tal verseucht und
vergiftet
und wurde es deswegen verlassen
als ich zum ersten mal her kam vor
ungefähr 30 jahren spürte ich gleich
dieses mysteriöse und den drang dem auf
den grund zu gehen
[Musik]
ainslie cox vom rat der grafschaft
cornwall hat die anlage intensiv
erforscht
im portal im mittleren westen cornwalls
sind wir in einer sehr ländlichen gegend
aber um mich herum sehen sie bröckelnde
mauern die auf eine industrielle
vergangenheit verweisen
das tal war einst ein zentrum des
größten wirtschaftszweige der region dem
bergbau
[Musik]
cornwall ist berühmt für seine zehn
minen hier hat alles angefangen und hier
wurden diese ganzen techniken entwickelt
das 10 wurde weltweit exportiert es war
der anfang der industriellen revolution
war mitte des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
die wohl wichtigste bergbauregion der
welt
und die produktion von kupfer und vor
allem von 10 war der grund dafür
aber dies hier sind nicht bloß die
überbleibsel einer zinn oder kupfermine
was hier abgebaut wurde war sehr viel
gefährlicher es hätte millionen menschen
töten können
[Musik]
diese anlage war das herzstück eines
handels netzwerks das hoch wirksames
gift weltweit vertrieben hat
welche tödlich giftige chemikalie wurde
hier also produziert und welchen zweck
diente sie
[Musik]
ursprünglich ging es in cornwall und
zinn dafür gab es einen markt und das
war profit ab und alles was den profit
im wege stand war ein störfaktor
und einer der größten störfaktoren war
sehen ein tödlich giftige störfaktor
geruch und geschmacklos dabei hoch
wirksam arsen ist ein tückisches gift
und in den minen kann man ihm nicht
entkommen
interessant am 10 wow ist das szenario
weise auch arsen und schwefel in
ziemlich hoher konzentration enthalten
normalerweise versucht man diese stoffe
so schnell wie möglich abzuschneiden
weil die hochgiftig sind vor allem
ansehen
das ist paul death valley hier bauten
arbeiter über 100 jahre lang ansehen ab
im neunzehnten jahrhundert wurde vom
abbau von kupfer und zinn auf die
förderung von gift umgestellt aber wer
brauchte arsen in großen mengen
[Musik]
das gelände ist eingezäunt damit niemand
darum läuft und sich vergiftet aber man
sieht das labyrinth das drinnen angelegt
ist
[Musik]
in diesen labyrinthen wurde das pure
asien gesammelt
zuerst wird das geförderte eisenerz auf
540 grad erhitzt dabei wird das arsen
gasförmig und trennt sich vom erz das
gas wird aufgefangen und in diese
labyrinthisch angelegten kammern
geleitet wo es abkühlt und
auskristallisiert
dann wurden die türen entriegelt und
geöffnet
die arbeiter gingen da rein mit schaufel
und besen und kratzten den arsenhaltigen
ruß von boden und wänden des labyrinths
im neunzehnten jahrhundert boomt der
handel mit arsen und entsprechende
bergwerke eröffnen im ganzen tal
[Musik]
bei den 1800 70er jahren kam die hälfte
des weltweiten asiens aus anlagen in
cornwall
[Musik]
das potenziell tödliche erzeugnis ist
aus verschiedenen gründen stark
nachgefragt
ab ungefähr 1800 wurden immer mehr
verschiedene rohstoffe gefördert
einer davon war sehen ein tödliches gift
es scheint schwer nachvollziehbar was
der grund war aber man brauchte es aus
allen möglichen gründen auf der ganzen
welt
im laufe der industriellen revolution
wird entdeckt dass arsen für die
herstellung verschiedener produkte
nützlich ist
sehen war plötzlich überall gefragt als
wichtiger inhaltsstoff für tapeten bei
der herstellung von glas und
schrotpatronen in der pharmaindustrie
zur desinfektion von schafen asien war
das wundermittel des frühen 19ten
jahrhunderts
es ist sogar in make up für einen
besonders vornehm blassen
ta10 ist teil des alltagslebens im
neunzehnten jahrhundert die
leidtragenden sind diejenigen die das
gift fördern
das lief ja nicht maschinell alles wurde
von hand gemacht mit schaufeln wurde das
ansehen von den wänden gekratzt
es gab keine sicherheitsvorkehrungen
oder schutzkleidung für die arbeiter
manche schmücken sich mit tonerde ein
oder schützten ihr gesicht mit feuchten
tüchern wie man sich vorstellen kann hat
das nichts genutzt
10 über längere zeit ausgesetzt zu sein
hat schlimme folgen
[Applaus]
verträge die arbeiter wurden kraftlos
und bekam magenkrämpfe hohe dosen
führten zu schockzuständen und
schließlich zum tod
manche schuften sich buchstäblich zu
tode
ein teelöffel dieses gift ist eine
tödliche dosis für sechs menschen
es dauert nicht lange bis noch viel mehr
menschen durch arsen getötet werden
im ersten weltkrieg werden erstmals
moderne chemische waffen eingesetzt
teils mit arsen aus cornwall
chlorgas senfgas und fonds gehen sollen
den stellungskrieg an der westfront
beenden
der tod durch giftgas ist oft langsam
und qualvoll
soldaten auf allen seiten fürchten die
schrecklichen neuen waffen
[Musik]
aber ob das giftgas erfolgreich
eingesetzt werden kann hängt vom wetter
ab
starker wind kann das gas verwehen und
wirkungslos machen
schlimmstenfalls wird es direkt wieder
auf die eigenen männer zurück geblasen
wirkliche taktische erfolge bringt das
giftgas nicht und in england wird immer
klarer dass anhaltender kontakt mit
arsen schwere gesundheitsschäden auslöst
sowohl in der pharmaindustrie als auch
in der landwirtschaft
schließlich können die gefahren nicht
mehr ignoriert oder abgestritten werden
dass bei arsen war zwar in vielen
medizinischen produkten enthalten aber
als zunehmend bekannt wurde wie giftig
und krebserregend assist kam der handel
damit zum erliegen
nur ein bergwerk in cornwall produziert
weiter sehen bis zum beginn des zweiten
weltkriegs
bis 1939 wurde weiter gefördert dann
kamen andere chemikalien auf die als
insektizide und so weiter eingesetzt
wurden asien wurde nicht mehr in so
großen mengen gebraucht wie im
neunzehnten jahrhundert
als die bergwerke schließen berät die
giftige vergangenheit des tals langsam
in vergessenheit bis
bodenanalysen ergeben dass die erde
immer noch hohe konzentrationen von
arsen enthält das gelände muss erst
dekontaminiert werden bevor es
öffentlich zugänglich gemacht werden
kann
heute ist das tal ein naturschutzgebiet
die meisten besucher haben keine ahnung
von dessen dunkler vergangenheit direkt
unter ihren füßen
[Musik]
in der türkischen provinz mugla steht
eine ruinenstadt mit einer
jahrhundertealten geschichte
wenn man von der anatolischen küste
durch die pinienwälder ins landesinnere
kommt öffnet sich ein weites tal erst
wenn man näher hinsieht merkt man da
stimmt was nicht
es ist ein zerstörtes dorf das
zweifellos schon vor langer zeit
aufgegeben wurde
in just cause es geht einfach immer
weiter es ist riesig
an den hängen des tals stehen aber
hunderte verlassener gebäude
[Musik]
zwischen den grundmauern wachsen bäume
die dächer sind eingestürzt alles ist
überwuchert ist
ein schatten seiner selbst
so wie es hier aussieht muss etwas
wirklich einschneidende es passiert sein
das kann keine kleinigkeit gewesen sein
war es eine naturkatastrophe oder krieg
die leute sind in massen geflohen aber
warum
die ruinen sind über den ganzen hang
verteilt als stumme zeugnisse einer
ereignisreichen vergangenheit
diese stadt ist fast 1000 jahre alt sie
war früher einmal recht wohlhabend
der ort muss einmal einen gewissen
stellenwert gehabt haben das sind ja
keine beraten die lage ist sehr gut für
den regionalen und auch für den
internationalen handel man spürt diese
alten tiefen wurzeln hier
die bewohner des ortes pflegten enge
beziehungen mit den bauern in der gegend
aber es gab einen bestimmten unterschied
zwischen den beiden gruppen
die architektur verrät eine menge über
die menschen hier aber es sind nicht nur
wohnhäuser erhalten es gibt ein gebäude
das noch steht und das den
entscheidenden hinweis über das
geheimnis dieses ortes liefert
diese anlage ist fantastisch es ist eine
siedlung der griechen die hier für viele
hundert jahre gelebt haben
über jahrhunderte gehörte diese region
zum osmanischen reich das riesige
muslimische imperium war grundsätzlich
tolerant gegenüber anderen religionen
und kulturen
auch gegenüber den menschen die hier
gelebt haben
dies sind die ruinen der stadt
kajak-einer gemeinde christlicher
griechen die es schon lange nicht mehr
gibt
[Musik]
das war eine christliche gemeinde und
auf der anderen seite des tals lebten
die türken sie waren nachbarn
muslime und christen lebten friedlich
zusammen in einer multikulturellen
gemeinschaft
[Musik]
in vielen teilen der welt spielen
identität ethnische zugehörigkeit und
kultur im alltag gar keine rolle an
andere gesellschaften halten zusammen
und die leute leben ihr leben
aber genau an diesen faktoren haben sich
einige der blutigsten konflikte der
geschichte entzündet
über 500 jahre lang leben und arbeiten
christen und muslime hier seite an seite
sie treffen sich täglich im gewirr der
straßen
das hier ist eine typische straße in
krakau hier standen verschiedene gebäude
wohnhäuser und ladengeschäfte die kinder
spielten zusammen auf solchen straßen
christen und muslime tauschten sich aus
über geschäftliches handel und ganz
normale alltagsthemen
[Musik]
die hier lebten zwei gemeinden einklang
die leute waren untereinander befreundet
die stadt floriert über jahrhunderte
aber als das osmanische reich anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts seinem ende
entgegen geht entstehen die ersten
probleme
live in das leben in krakau sollte sich
ändern die lebensbedingungen die politik
alles auch der alltag der leute
aber welche zerstörerische kraft hat
hier gewütet und was ist mit den
menschen geschehen die hier zu hause
waren
die antwort liegt in den unruhigen
jahren nach dem ersten weltkrieg als das
osmanische reich zusammenbricht entsteht
ein konflikt zwischen zwei
nationalistischen bewegungen
im ries in griechenland gab es
bestrebungen nach einem neuen
byzantinischen reich
die türken hingegen wollten eine
republik für alle ethnischen türken
gründen
diese beiden interessen standen im
gegensatz zueinander
der konflikt eskaliert immer mehr kleine
friedliche ländliche gemeinden werden
hineingezogen
trotz jahrhundertelanger harmonie
zwischen diesen bevölkerungsgruppen
führte der krieg auf beiden seiten zu
grausamkeit folter und brutalen
ausschreitungen
[Musik]
wir wissen von verbrechen der griechen
gegenüber den türken mord zerstörung von
häusern und so weiter und auch von
verbrechen der türken brandstiftung und
die ermordung von griechen
[Musik]
bis 1922 werden hunderttausende griechen
und türken im krieg getötet
schließlich einigen sich die beiden
seiten auf einen zwangsweisen
bevölkerungs tauschen das bedeutet auch
gemeinden wie immer gut mit dem nachbarn
aus gekommen waren müssen das land
verlassen
das hier ist ein beispiel für ein
griechisches haus in krakau
das hier war mal die küche
als sie erfuhren dass sie nach
griechenland umziehen müssen warten sie
ihre nachbarn die muslimischen türken
auf ihre häuser aufzupassen
sie gingen davon aus bald zurückzukehren
aber sie kamen nie wieder
eine halbe million ethnische türken die
in griechenland lebten wurden enteignet
und in die türkei gebracht
und ungefähr anderthalb millionen
ethnische griechen die oft in eigenen
griechischen ortschaften lebten wurden
aus der türkei vertrieben
[Musik]
wieder ist diese wunderschöne fröhliche
stadt in der christen und muslime seite
an seite leben
dann wird sie aufgegeben und ihre seele
herausgerissen
1957 erschüttert dann noch ein erdbeben
die verlassene stadt
viele häuser stürzen heim werden
zerstört aber eigentlich war ihr
schicksal vorher schon besiegelt
solche um siedlungs maßnahmen haben
folgen die man nicht unterschätzen darf
denn sie wirken sich auf die lebensweise
der menschen aus wenn man den menschen
ihre kultur und geschichte nimmt bleibt
ihnen nichts denn das ist es doch was
eine gemeinschaft ausmacht
[Musik]
einst starben hier tausende auf befehl
des naziregimes
noch immer geben die ruinen rätsel auf
in diesen verfallenden bauten sind die
echos der geschichte hörbar sie könnten
von erfindergeist und menschlichen
streben nach fortschritt aber auch von
krieg und terror